oh
[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour cette vidéo en extérieur et
aujourd'hui je suis accompagné de julien
salut à tous voilà qui va m'aider parce
que on as des questions auxquelles on
doit répondre aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on
va parler du nourrissage des oiseaux
alors j'avais fait une vidéo sur le
sujet de l'année dernière vous ferez
consulter d'ailleurs je mettrai le lien
en d'expression et je lis pas mal de
questions retour sur cette vidéo à
propos du nourrissage des oiseaux parce
que ça j'ai pas expliqué j'explique et
commandera les oiseaux mais j'ai pas
expliquer pourquoi et aujourd'hui on va
parler du pourquoi alors se basant
notamment sur un livre un livre que j'ai
trouvé très intéressant et que je vous
recommande de lire d'ailleurs si vous
savez lire l'anglais parce que
malheureusement c'est un bouquin qui se
trouve uniquement en anglais les
chercher mais j'ai pas trouvé traduction
et ça s'appelle de
23,2 à noailles et matelas
donc traduction les oiseaux à ma table
juste pourquoi nous nourrissons les
oiseaux et pourquoi c'est important
donc ce livre il est intéressant
pourquoi parce qu'il est écrit par un
auteur qui est extrêmement intéressant
qui démarre comme ce qui est un
professeur émérite à l'université de
griffe et en australie et donc terreur
jones ici connaît vraiment en oiseaux et
en écologie principalement il a écrit ce
bouquin parce que pour lui c'était
vraiment intéressant de demander un peu
à travers le monde à différentes
personnes comment il voyait le
nourrissage des oiseaux de quidam moyen
et qu'est ce que ça apporte et de nos
réalisateurs ou au contraire qu est ce
que ça pouvait engendrer comme problème
comme conséquence pour tout pour tous
les wheeler écoulée et donc il a compilé
ce bouquin qui est basé sur des années
et des années de recherches
scientifiques avec des références
absolument incroyable non vraiment si
vous l'avez pas lu je vous conseille de
le dire allez y faire un tour parce
qu'on va vraiment se baser là dessus
aujourd'hui pour la discussion
va faire pleins d'idées reçues énorme et
c'est aussi très intéressant avec des
runs c'est qu'il est australien et en
australie un débat absolument énorme sur
le nourrissage des docks faut-il swing
ne faut-il pas nourrir les oiseaux parce
que en nourrissant les deux membres il y
aussi des espèces invasives et du coup
c'est un véritable problème
principalement en agglomération parce
que ça se fait au détriment des espèces
sont locales donc il ya un très très
gros débat à ce sujet et on va voir un
peu comment être qu'il a pris la chose
et comment il envisage la fin du match
et aux hausses en australie donc c'est
vraiment bien d'avoir aussi un avis de
ce côté du monde en france c'est vrai
qu'on a un peu moi l'australie c'est
bien pour pourvoir à l'assaut de cette
dichotomie entre footing ne faut-il pas
nourrir les autres
quand on parle nourrissage des oiseaux
on pense immédiatement appuyé du grain
au pigeon nos pigeons espèce invasive
par excellence nous filer deux derniers
temps on a l'image de la personne qui
donne plus fort au canard
c'est
c'est aussi d'autres problèmes donc
voilà je pensais qu'aujourd'hui c'était
intéressant de se poser dans un coin ma
foi fort sympathique pour en discuter un
petit peu et qui vous entendez si vous
écoutez bien dans la vidéo vous pourrez
entendre aussi
tous les oiseaux tourner autour de nous
alors aujourd'hui on a des weaver donc
j'ai des tisserins qui font leur nid
juste la dent large face à la caméra
sont très marrant si vous les voyez pas
c'est le mal et un jaune mais alors
pétant avec un masque noir
man river qui est de ce côté là on a des
échoppes qui sont des petits oiseaux
très prévoyant aussi notamment les mâles
qui vont être noir et voilà c'est très
mignon vous me voyez passer c'est sympa
garde
[Musique]
donc la question principale de cette
vidéo qu'on va se poser aujourd'hui ça
va être est ce que je devrais y loin des
eaux sauvages oui et pour ce faire on va
avoir plein de petites questions
subalternes qui donc permettre de savoir
si ça marche ou pas quels sont les
problèmes qu'on peut offrir vos contrats
des avantages qu'il y ait choisi parce
que oui c'est vrai qu'il ya des
problèmes on cite régulièrement au
niveau des oiseaux sauvages et de
vernissage qui est notamment la
dépendance va des oiseaux à la mangeoire
à laquelle devient un fléau des cons les
nourrit tous les jours
on a des problèmes de maladies peuvent
survenir parce qu'évidemment des oiseaux
qu'on s'entend même endroit je veux
apporter de maladie on va avoir des
problèmes de mauvaise nutrition si vous
nourrissez pas avec la les bonnes
graines avec les bonnes choses avec les
bonnes graisses par exemple en hiver
vous a fait du pas du pain typique mois
on pouvait avoir aussi est-ce que mettre
une mangeoire là est ce que ça ne
rentrerait pas justement un changement
dans la répartition naturelle des
espèces de c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut se poser comme question et puis
d'un autre côté vous avez tous les
bénéfices qu'on peut avoir dû aux
mangeoires qu'ils vont être on va on va
les aider pendant l'hiver à survivre
tout simplement ça peut être déjà bien
vu qu'on a des populations en baisse
ça peut aider aussi lors de la
reproduction avoir un peu plus de fade
de quoi manger pour être beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus efficace en cas de
reproduction avoir plus d'eux peut-être
devenus de puissants
et puis ça peut engendrer au niveau du
grand public un intérêt dans la
conservation des espèces qui n'est pas
négligeable parce que du coup ça permet
d'avoir des gens qui s'intéressent à la
biodiversité et ça
fait de ces soirs d'hiver
donc ce classement lors ici essayer de
faire le tri entre toutes ces
affirmations lesquels sombre et
lesquelles sont fausses et comment est
ce qu'on peut leur répondre
justin qui impulsent clémeur un petit
truc avant qu'on commence on comprend
pas encore à l'heure actuelle
exactement comment nous influençons la
répartition des espèces ou comment nous
d'inspiration tout simplement les
oiseaux sauvages en les nourrissant on a
quelques mois de réflexion évidemment
mais on sait pattes parce qu'il n'y a
pas beaucoup de gens qui sont intéressés
à ce sujet notamment au nourrissage des
oiseaux en guil particulièrement à ce
que ben
tout simplement le concept d'écologie
urbaine c'est un concept développé
seulement très récemment et du coup il
n'y a pas grand monde qui s'y est
intéressé il n'y a pas encore eu le
temps d'avoir beaucoup beaucoup de
recherches à ce sujet beaucoup de
complications donc on va on va faire
avec ce qu'on a pour l'instant ce que
l'on va dire aujourd'hui il n'est pas
impossible que ça change d'ici les
prochaines années
les chercheurs vont s'intéresser plus en
plus le genre de choses nous voilà
prenez ce qu'on dit aujourd'hui avec des
pincettes parce que il est possible que
dans le futur proche ça change vous
allez voir dans ce qu'on va dire
aujourd'hui aussi il ya des choses qui
ont déjà changé dans le châssis ils vont
certainement encore changé elle est
comme tout en sciences 1 tout est vrai
jusqu'à preuve du contraire
[Musique]
alors est ce qu on pourrait commencer
avec la première question pour
aujourd'hui
je vais pas répondre non sinon c'est la
vider l'eau
là semble être un bon point allons-y
donc
alors la première question qu'on
pourrait se poser c'est pourquoi est ce
que c'est important pour prendre en fait
l'impact qu'a le nourrissage des oiseaux
sur les populations sauvages est ce
qu'on peut pas juste de recruter des
trucs à manger puis bah il se débrouille
et ce ne sera pas si simple balancer les
graines et dieu reconnaîtra les siens
pourquoi est ce que c'est important de
comprendre cette chose là bas si je
pense qu'il faut commencer là pour
répondre à temps pour commencer à
répondre à cette question je pense qu'il
faut commencer par le début c'est que on
a cette image de l'oiseau en fait ce qui
est l'image du petit machin
généralement brun va très coloré en tout
cas en europe en europe soutient donc le
petit machin brin lemoine au camp comme
ça et qui mange des graines en fait on a
vraiment ce stéréotype du mangeur de
graines chez les oiseaux qui est pas
qu'ils evren juste pour une toute petite
partie des oiseaux
oui
oui on donne du pain aux canards et on
donne des graines aux oiseaux genre tous
les oiseaux sont carnivores et tous les
canards sont
pas là parce que c'est quand on se
nourrit exclusivement de par l'opac à
l'intérêt on a deux amours et les
canards de passe comme ça bref il ya des
stéréotypes en fait ces cinq si c'est ça
c'est à dire on aura pas l'idée on
n'aura pas l'idée en tant que le
personne qui n'est pas éduqué à la
nourrissage des oiseaux d'aller chercher
des vers de farine typiquement on va les
nourrir tous les oiseaux insectivores
alors sèchement majoritairement un site
mais c'est vrai que c'est cette image
très ancré dans la culture est souvent
il ya les grands parents qui prennent
des enfants pour aller au parc pour
aller nourrir les canards c'est la
sortie du dimanche voilà c'est normal ou
alors lors du pique nique on a des
petits restes de noces corrigeant les
balances toute la zone puis voilà et
c'est tout à fait normal
le problème avec cette image c'est que
on oublie un peu vite que beaucoup
d'oiseaux en fait nos dimanches france a
à aucun des problèmes à leur
alimentation
sans l'impact qu'on a sur ces
populations là et puis il faut pas il
faut aussi se souvenir que
les
le business en fait des nourrissage des
oiseaux c'est quelque chose d'assez
énorme bluff l'impact du nourrissage
d'une sauvage on pourrait se dire que
oui bon c'est juste quelques personnes
qui mettent des trucs à manger dans une
mangeoire dans leur jardin le plus fier
tout ça pas beaucoup d'impact oui
lorsque j'ai quelques chiffres là et il
faut se rendre compte qu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de foyers dans le monde qui
nourrissent et de l'eau sauvage et
particulièrement dans les pays pourront
simuler sa comme la france l'europe en
deux jours à l'oiseau notamment au
royaume-uni extrêmement connue pour les
oiseaux sauvages
l'australie aussi en australie certains
films de disney pour deux peines
[Rires]
en australie il ya aussi à peu près
50% des foyers qui vont nourrir les
oiseaux sauvages par exemple pour ça et
c'est de guerre entre jeunes ou
régionaux histoire 50 50
en nouvelle zélande c'est aussi la
moitié des foyers qui nous est ce au dos
sauvage en angleterre on a plus de 50%
on à 55 % jusqu'à 70% en moyenne 60% en
fait
une instruction si vous êtes la campagne
mon envie qu'ils vont nouvelles au
chômage
aux usa on est pareils autour de ça avec
entre 43 et 74 % des foyers qui
devraient se battre ça fait beaucoup
plus lent au niveau du business
rien que sur le royaume uni on a 400 à
peu près 450 millions de dollars qui
sont versés chaque année pour nourrir
les oiseaux quatre centrales en dehors
du coup
principalement mais il ya beaucoup
d'autres choses aussi ce qui se sont
développées récemment mais 450 millions
de dollars juste pour le royaume uni
dans cette industrie faut quand même se
rendre compte que c'est quelque chose de
deux massifs
voilà c'est ce cas là si on sait en
balançait tout cet argent là pour la
conservation des cétacés on aurait pu
n'être qu'une autre en europe la planète
de baleine
c'est ça mais
après les usa j'avais un autre chiffre
qui est intéressant aussi si on est à
450 millions de kilos cette fois-ci de
graines seulement de graignes ils sont
chaque année ce produit est utilisé pour
la forêt nos messages et les autres dans
les jardins 450 juste aux états unis
juste aux états unis voilà je travaille
avec l'eau chauffe qui crie jon mange
pas de regrets
or c'est un aigle au chaud d'épingler à
ton mur
si vous vivez aux nouvelles situations
et peindre la somo à ta porte
au québec car c'est bien canada oui dit
il m'apporte nous rien n'est que l'autre
chose
donc il faut bien se rendre compte tout
ça pour dire qu'il faut bien se rendre
compte que oui
l'alimentation tout ce qu'on donne notre
dos des jardins du coup on est
énormément dans le monde à le faire ç'a
un impact et sa salle en face lui la
question maintenant c'est de savoir
lequel il a déjà la répartition
j'imagine la répartition des populations
parce que du coup si on les attire dans
des parce que c'est principalement des
centres urbains j'imagine sans son
mentor oui c'est vrai que les novices h
à la campagne c'est un peu moi c'est
moins répandue dont le faire donc c'est
surtout aurait pas en influence la
répartition des populations je suppose
on
favorise du coup les granivores à mort
oui
et puis on et puis on les attire près du
sol là où ils sont vulnérables aux chats
pas forcément parce que il ya beaucoup
de il ya beaucoup de choses maintenant
sur les sièges aux ados et notamment pas
le royaume uni et en australie même en
france d'ailleurs ça s'est beaucoup
développée et beaucoup de gens
maintenant compris que le message de 2
séparent le sol tout ça c'est forcément
ça se fait sur des mangeoires sont
généralement hauteur et qui sont
protégés des chats d'une certaine
manière ça marche pas toujours mais
deschamps ou d'autres choses mais
c'est un geste anodin en fait balancer
du pain ou des graines au sol mais faut
voir que pour beaucoup d'oiseaux c'est
pas du tout un comportement naturel
d'aller chercher à manger sur le sol
mais il ya des espèces qu'ils font est
typiquement le rouge doit un peu passion
des armes ça ça va chercher ce nouvel
heureux ça lui fera de temps en temps
parce qu'autant donc ils mangent
d'autres mais ça va chercher de la
nourriture au sol de temps en temps le
qu'il vend aussi notamment mais pour le
reste nous occupe il ment les mésanges
la maison je ne soutiendra pas le sol
pour manger vos graines et paraissait en
hauteur dans les arbres
ne verrez pas descendre ou non les
pistes restent ouvertes
on vous en prendre à la jambe
la fin de la saison unification
d'antenne ils sont encore occupés
[Musique]
sbo la deuxième grande question c'est
celle qui nourrit les autres ce que
c'est vrai qu'on a vu donc
les gens qui nous ont essayé d'autres
dans certains pays il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de monde noyer 2e mais est-ce
que c'est partout pareil en l'occurrence
non et il se trouve qu'en fait on a un
billet c'est assez intéressant
d'ailleurs c'est qu'on a des pays ils
sont les plus pointues sont généralement
ceux qui vont le plus nourrir les
oiseaux tout simplement pourquoi parce
que l'on considère qu'en hiver on a
besoin de supplémenter un peu
l'alimentation des oiseaux
survivre tout simplement voir ce simple
que ça donc on va avoir le royaume uni
le nord des états unis vous allez avoir
de la suisse l'irlande l'islande
la hongrie l'australie la belgique le
danemark l'australie qui est pas
vraiment aux normes et qu'il est très au
sud dans l'hémisphère sud à se regarder
et vous avez
aussi des filles qui vont qui sont un
peu moins froid comme la france qui a
franchement un climat méditerranéen que
tu te seras pas ce
qui va aussi ouvrir tunnel des oiseaux
ou alors voir même des pays qui sont
carrément plus au sud un comme le brésil
l'espagne qui vont aussi pas mal non
elle est nommée un peu moins et du coup
de la consommation de graines point le
message va être un peu moins en fait je
jure à l'échelle du marché mondial ce
qui intéresse mais on voit qu'il ya une
dimension sociale aussi un nourrissage
au nourrissage des oiseaux parce que là
ce que tu ne voulait me dire c'est pas
seulement le nord géographique c'est
aussi le nord économique selena
économique effective des gens qui ont
les moyens aussi de mettre de l'argent
dans balance est littéralement de la
bouffe par les fenêtres là pour le coup
c'est vrai c'est ton sac en afrique
notamment le pays le plus influent dans
la dans l'utilisation de graines et de
mangeoires pour les oiseaux c'est la
poudre messieurs c'est le ticket de plus
en plus nous organiser
il ya c'est aussi apparemment tu disais
qu'il fallait c'est beaucoup des pays
anglo saxons donc l'ancienne en tenir
oui britannique en quelque sorte oui
c'est vrai
du coup si tu as une culture du
nourrissage qui se développement en
angleterre du coup elle se répand assez
précis
en fait en angleterre ce qui était
marrant c'est que la sas expliqué
l'ancien si vous disais ça c'est que le
nourrissage des oiseaux ne sait pas
forcément c'est dans une période faste
ça n'a pas vraiment démarré dans une
période faste où vous effectivement on
aurait tous pris soin de la nourriture
apparences et la balance aux oiseaux
c'est pas le cas du tout c'est une
période où en fait les hivers sont
devenus extrêmement rigoureux et on a vu
des oiseaux morts par centaines par
milliers et ils mourraient vraiment de
froid et de faim dans les campagnes et
c'est là où en fait le gouvernement même
jusqu'au gouvernement a commencé à
inciter les gens à nourrir les animaux
sauvages et a donné avec des recettes
qu'on nous rase serre dépend de grève et
pour moi les sauvages dans la nature
dias pas été c'était une pas forcément
une période faste parce qu'il fait très
froid et donc la récolte n'est pas ici
mais ça a commencé c'est là parce qu'on
a commencé à avoir un impact en fait sur
l'emploi sauvage ans ne se fait pas
[Musique]
enfin bref et du coup ça nous amène à la
question si longue s'est vu que c'est
les pays majoritairement dans les
endroits froid
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il faut
nourrir majoritairement en hiver les
autres parce que c'est un thème qui
revient régulièrement et dans toutes les
questions qu'on m'a posée aussi c'était
toujours ça c'était il faut arrêter de
nous rire quand le printemps arrive
alors que c'est la saison 2 reprend
généralement alors que c'est assez
sombre pour effectivement c'est là
qu'ils ont besoin de nourriture donc ça
c'est le côté contre intuitif en fait il
faudrait nous vers les oiseaux
finalement quand ils sont moins actifs
ouais mais il ya une raison à ça c'est
effectivement en hiver ils ont besoin
des visions des besoins supplémentaires
parce qu'il n'y a plus beaucoup de
nourriture retour et que c'est une
difficile de chercher à manger sa
dépense beaucoup plus d'énergie tout
simplement certes si vous volez un petit
peu pour aller chercher à manger d'aller
dépenser beaucoup d'énergie ce qui se
tramait et si les choses parce qu'on
puisse pour maintenir en température
corporelle
ça demande des calculs en fait c'est que
c'est plus compliqué en hiver donc ils
sont contents d'avoir un petit
supplément
messari qu'au printemps quand on
commence à repro il s'attire quand même
aussi pas mal sur les deux ans parce que
la femelle de procéder eux ensuite de
niche et c'est vrai que ça demande
beaucoup d'énergie pour les parts du
pouvoir qu au niveau des oiseaux enfin
si vous regardez cette vidéo c'est que
vous êtes déjà plus ou moins familiers
avec la biologie des oiseaux mais enfin
oiseaux
l'oiseau standard atteint sa taille
adulte en allemand en gros pas en une
saison en quelques
mois les plus petites espèces en un mois
et demi deux mois n'était pas voilà donc
un flux d'énergie qui doit atteindre le
petit et en même temps les parents qui
doivent continuer à survivre qui a eu
raison c'est ça et des parents sont
obligés de voler toute la journée pour
aller chercher à manger pendant l'assaut
il se pose pas un instant ils ont pas
vraiment et c'est là que c'est là qu'il
faudrait arrêter de les nourrir d'après
la croyance populaire alors la croyance
populaire est pas basé sur n'importe
quoi non plus vrai qu'il faut bien se
rendre compte que il ya quand même des
problèmes qui ont été notés et qui ont
fait que on a décidé d'arrêter nourrir
au printemps c'est que on pensait jusqu
à récemment que les parents tu prenais
en fait la nourriture ce qui était
proposé dans les mangeoires pour noah
leur petit c'est à dire qu'ils allaient
utiliser des graines et les cacahuètes
parfois truc énorme là pour mettre dans
le cosi de leur petit et que ça va
entraîner des problèmes du coup de
croissance chez les poteaux parce
qu'évidemment c'est pas le genre de
nourriture qui peut donner un
petit oiseau en pleine croissance
généralement les souvent les petits en
fera forcément le même régime
alimentaire
cet hiver par exemple parce que pas
attendre beaucoup trouvent de 30min ont
grandi à grande vitesse des deux enfants
de plus de protéines
pour grandir que leurs parents les
parents peuvent se contenter d'un résumé
avec des graines et comme ça mais les
petits et pas forcément donc en
s'inquiéter en fait de l'impact
qu'aurait la nourriture pour proposer
dans les mangeoires sur la croissance
des oisillons et c'est tout à fait
normal mais il se trouve que ya
plusieurs défis tu as mieux qu'on était
fait et en l'occurrence les parents sont
tout à fait capables de distinguer ce
qui est bon pour leur petit nid et ce
qui ne l'est pas
curieusement curieusement et donc il ne
donne pas à manger des trucs que l'été
qui normalement ne pourrait pas manger
et il se trouve que les écuries ont
prouvé dans la majorité des cas 90% de
la nourriture qui est donné au petit
vent fait est de la nourriture capturé
ce qu'on trouve pas sur les nids sur les
suppléments voir
donc ce n'est pas vraiment un problème
de proposer de la nourriture en touche
pendant que les parents ont leur niche
et parce que de toute façon il est
nourri rompt pas avec ça ne sera pas
pour un problème il réussit cette
histoire de quelqu'un parce qu'on a
retrouvé des oisillons qui sont étouffés
avec une cacahuète qui étaient énormes
que leurs parents essaient de ce lycée
dans le gosier saadé plusieurs fois et
quelqu'un qui avait été proposé donc sur
une mangeoire et on se disait ma main si
on propose des cacahuètes aux parents
ils vont maintenant essayer de nouvelles
à leur niche et avec ça il se trouve
qu'en fait même en proposant les
différences qui ont été faites comme ça
et même en proposant des cacahuètes sur
les mangeoires pour les parents ils ne
prennent les cacahuètes que dans un état
vraiment d'extrême urgence c'est à dire
qu'ils ont retrouvez d'autres pour leurs
petits dans la nature au sport etc
qui sont complètement désespéré ce
niveau là c'est qu'ils savent plus quoi
faire donc ils prennent le dernier truc
qu'ils ont pu trouver épuisé c'est de
faire en sorte que le petit survivre
c'est vraiment le le dernier truc qu'ils
essaient de faire avant que c'est énorme
c'est pas c'est pas vraiment c'est pas
un geste anodin chez comme nourrir votre
bébé avec une noix de coco
des pigments vous ne feriez pas
vraiment la dalle non je ne riez pas
voilà donc ça c'est faux pas se souvient
ce temps que les oiseaux ne sont pas non
plus des deals et qui savent plus ou
moins ce qui est bon pour leurs petits
même lorsque c'est leur première niche
et que ce soit
l'apprentissage quoi ce généralement de
l'instinct pour les petites espèces mais
il s'est il satisfait à redonner à leur
petit dont ils vont pas prendre
n'importe quoi sur les mangeurs pour
l'arche il est normalement c'est pas un
problème
donc ça c'était c'était vraiment la
raison principale sur pourquoi il faut
pas nourrir
après l'hiver la deuxième raison c'est
qu'on avait peur que en fait les petits
ne sache pas se débrouiller vu qu'une
fois que tu serais sorti denis les
parents finirez par les emmener à
l'amour joueur aura montré le camp où il
ya à manger
et on dit les bains à cause de ça ils
apprendront pas à chasser à trouver leur
nourriture tout seul sait combien et il
se trouve que non
pas du tout il ya aussi des expériences
qui ont été faites comme ça et tu es en
l'occurrence vous pouvez nourrir des
ados pendant ce principe et 25 ans qui
défile temps sur 25 ans une vieille
nourrice il avait nourri des oiseaux
pendant 25 ans et puis tout d'un coup
après 25 ans ils ont arrêté les
mangeoires ouch rien et ils ont regardé
si les autorités car à se dérouiller ou
pas et il se trouve que il ya eu
autant de mortalité que d'habitude c'est
à dire que les oiseaux ne savent plus si
la population à rester stable
donc oui même après 25 ans de
nourrissage à fond sur des mangeoires
ils ont bien des gens sains sans aucun
problème faut bien se rendre compte que
nous humains on est quand même une
addition très récente est ce qu'il se
passe dans l'environnement et que c'est
pas avec nous au revoir on va faire
autre chose que juste supplémenté leur
alimentation donc c'est ça vraiment ce
que ça veut dire c'est que nous ce
moment voir tout ce qu'on est capable de
faire c'est d'offrir un supplément c'est
la nourriture sauvage s'ils peuvent la
voir dans la nature c'est là qu'ils vont
la chercher en premier parce que c'est
frais c'est bien si c'est quand même
mieux d'avoir un insecte tout s'est
plutôt que d'avoir une graine sur une
mangeoire généralement c'est comme ça
qu'ils voient la joute face à ce genre
d'anthropomorphisme en fait c'est à dire
que nous on est une espèce dont la
plupart des connaissances sont
acquises sont pas innées donc on a
l'impression en fait que ben voilà que
si on nourrit les oiseaux on va faire
des enfants gâtés c'est parce que c'est
ce qui arriverait avec nos enfants à
nous si on les nourrit trop longtemps si
vous les chaperonner trop vous avons
renvoyés dans leurs
familles et voilà mais non en fait les
frais et non sur tous les petits oiseaux
apparemment ce que tu disais ils ont
annoncé un très forte
ces millions d'années d'évolution
derrière ça c'est pas en quelques
dizaines d'années que ça va changer peu
plus
tard après des espèces plus
intelligentes comme les perroquets des
décors 10 et
éventuellement ils apprennent aussi mais
d'une expérience qui avaient été faites
sur des fils par exemple fin de ses
terres en australie parce qu'ils avaient
fait l'expérience il est proposé or seul
truc qui sont blanches beaucoup de
viande et notamment des réseaux frôlent
les petits sont nourries quasi
exclusivement avec de la viande séchée
draghi pour la croissance et il avait
proposé sur des mangeoires des petits
morceaux de viande exactement ce les
pires chercheur est normalement et
malgré ça les pieds au final ont choisi
de nourrir leur portée avec tous vase
tout sourire la nature et 90 pensions de
leur alimentation vous venez de la
nature n'est pas des manches
donc elle se nourrissait effectivement
sur les mangeoires mais les petits
étaient nourris avec ce que tes parents
pouvaient dans la nature le chat écrasé
c'est bien meilleur
on n'était pas sûr de la larve
l'acronyme pas mais parce que je pense
pas être sais pas
donc voilà donc je pense qu'il n'y a pas
vraiment lieu de s'inquiéter si voilà sa
réponse on peut se poser la question est
effectivement mais à mon avis il est
parti trop problème d'ailleurs la
plupart des grandes organisations
qui avaient un message très alarmiste il
ya encore une trentaine d'années en
disant non mais attention surtout
arrêter oprah fort ça suffit maintenant
le discours a complètement changé si
vous regardez les ordinations qui sont
au royaume uni par exemple bio et ce
genre de choses le message a
complètement changé eu un revirement et
maintenant tu te sens tu à nourrir toute
l'année si ça vous chante ce qui est
bien ça veut dire qu'ils savent
s'adapter aux données nouvelles oui
je sais je sais que des fois ça peut
être perturbant pour nous qui aimons
bien avoir une ligne droite comme ça et
on n'en change pas voilà en tout cas
voilà une belle ligne directive mais non
la vérité c'est que une organisation qui
base ses connaît à qui base ses
décisions sur des nouvelles données
scientifiques
c'est une organisation qui a un
fonctionnement sain l'organisation qui
ne change pas son mode de fonctionnement
malgré les nouvelles données c'est un
problème n'oubliez pas votre carte de
membre
ça prouve que justement il se base sur
la littérature scientifique et ça ça
c'est un gros plus
[Musique]
à
il ya aussi la question de pourquoi est
ce que maintenant on encourage au
contraire adresse toute l'année c'est
parce que il ya eu un déclin à très
important des populations d'oiseaux
récemment ces dernières dizaines
vingtaine d'années et on s'est rendu
compte soudainement que les oiseaux qui
nous étaient communs dans nos villes et
nos campagnes et bah il dit était plus
et là on se dit mince il ya un problème
et donc la supplémentation en hiver ne
suffisant plus à maintenir ces
populations la zone séguy et là il va
falloir apporter d'autres choses aussi
au printemps et en été pour les aider à
faire face à tout ce qu'on peut tout ce
qu'on peut leur mettre dessus parce que
le jeu ne sais pas si vous vous rendez
compte mais l'homme a un impact certain
sur son environnement et sa part la
destruction d'habitats par la pollution
par tout ce qu'on apporte avec nous que
ce soit des espèces invasives ou d'autre
chose on a un impact certain sur les
populations d'oiseaux il sur les choses
qu'elle prenne acte notamment les
enseignes on a beaucoup de rapports
dernièrement et puis d'ailleurs si vous
prenez le ton qui offrit à votre voiture
olga et tout de suite il ya beaucoup
moins dans cette micra neige sur votre
pare-brise que ce qu'ils avaient il ya
une dizaine d'années si vous faites 100
km sur la tente et ça c'est un réel
problème pour les populations d'oiseaux
qui se nourrissent de ces personnes
parce que du coup y'a plus rien à manger
donc si vous voulez soutenir la même
quantité de populations d'oiseaux que ce
qu'ils avaient il ya encore une dizaine
d'années est d'ailleurs falloir plus
jeunes voiture et cette nourriture on
peut la propose une dans les revoir à
condition de proposer les bonnes choses
évidemment pour ça je vous réfère à la
vidéo que j'avais fait à l arrière si
vous voulez aller y jeter un oeil voir
ce qu'on peut proposer par les
mangeoires pour les oiseaux il ya tout
ce qu'il faut pas que des graines et
quand même des graisses de graisses des
protéines
parce que du coup on peut fournir des
insectes oui fournir des conseils c'est
la fin d'un cycle si chez ou d'insectes
petit album tons faire un petit élevage
de vers de paris nice à moutons pas ce
plaisir aux enfants en plus
[Musique]
alors est-ce que le nourrissage par
montjoire est ce que c'est vraiment la
meilleure façon de 10 les oiseaux est ce
que ça aide vraiment j'ai dépensé toutes
ces tonnes de graines et tout cet effort
aurait dit
vraiment une différence entre
ça c'est vrai qu'on peut se poser la
question on sait que va falloir aider
les populations sauvages mais est-ce que
mettre des mangeoires c'est la meilleure
méthode
alors il ya plusieurs réponses à cette
question encore une fois ce qu'il faut
voir la chose différente
généralement la meilleure méthode qu'on
propose pour aider à restaurer une
population de sauvage c'est de restaurer
l'habitat naturel donc faire des
réserves naturelles ça en sorte que soit
pas polluée en mettre de la verdure un
peu dans les villes c'est donc restaurer
l'habitat naturel au maximum le problème
c'est que c'est une solution à long
terme l habitat naturel
pas juste comme ça alors que mike est
une grandeur entre jardin a élu ce
trimestre des jeunes sassus en dix
minutes
il est d'accord
et et du coup ça peut avoir un impact en
fait beaucoup plus immédiat sur les
populations sauvages
et il ya une autre chose
aussi qu'on oublie souvent c'est que m
au moment où la danse c'est pas fort
beaucoup de personnes en fait c'est pas
un acte qui va être solitaire c'est à
dire que on va avoir des gens qui vont
soudainement développé un intérêt pour
la faune sauvage de petits gâteaux et
qui vous dira mais tient à tanger
entendu parler d'un truc je peux fait
aménager un peu mon jardin par un petit
coin plus sympa pour les insectes pour
que j'ai plus d'oiseaux qui viennent et
qui viennent se nourrir dans ce petit
coin d'herbe folle parce qu'il fait
aménager en danse de salon je sais où je
tiens j'ai rajouté une mangeoire pour
boudeuse grèce tiens je vais faire ça
pour les colibris et du coup ça va en
fait engendré tout un intérêt et toute
une une refonte du jardin de la personne
en question qui va du coup de venir
adopter pour la faune sauvage déjà je
trouve ça assez incroyable parce que du
coup juste en partant de cette petite
mangeoire vous y avait tout d'un coup un
impact énorme sur toute la faune du coin
qui va se développer grâce à ça et ça on
oublie un petit peu mais voilà il ya
tout une réaction en chaîne qui peut se
produire chez des vins bus par
l'installation d'une seule manche soir
alors après vous allez me dire
effectivement les autres personnes qui
installe la manche ont laissé
complètement vidé une semaine après
d'accord mais pour toutes cette personne
d'années quand même une ou deux
personnes à côté qui vont faire en sorte
d'aménageur jardin pour les petites
espèces et ça ça faut pas l'oublier faut
pas négliger parce que c'est vraiment il
faut faire ça intelligemment par contre
parce que comme on l'a dit il ya des
problèmes majeurs c'est justement des
pesticides qui tuent les insectes qui
dont se nourrissent les oiseaux
n'achetez pas des graines
qui ont
pas qu'ils ont été cultivés dans des
trucs qui utilise du pesticide à tour de
bras parce que du coup pour les pour les
quelques d'oiseaux granivores que vous
allez aider avec ça vous allez en tués
combien qui sont insectivores
faut pas non plus faire n'importe
comment au niveau de la façon de donner
cette nourriture il est par exemple la
dernière fois on avait vu une vidéo avec
le chili oui mais filet avec la boule de
graisse dedans et donc cette personne
avait suspendu le filet et là on voit un
goéland qui se ramènent qui attrape le
filet louf qu'ils optent tout entier que
la bouteille de 6 kg groupe tout entier
ouais donc il va digérer la boule de
graisse par contre le filet va rester
pour toujours dans ce monde
il va rester aussi par en faire des
blocages intestinaux ça va être génial
donc oui il faut nourrir intelligemment
évidemment pas faire n'importe quoi mais
ça on en avait parlé dans la vidéo aussi
ne pas la qualité de la nourriture que
vous offrez aux oiseaux est aussi
importante que ce que vous offrez un
c'est à dire que si vous vous offrez des
nourritures basse et comme pour nous
aussi on veut manger du fast food tous
les jours
typiquement vous allez avoir des tas de
problèmes après de santé baleato c'est
pareil pouvait pas leur offrir du fast
food
et adaptée à leur espèce alors besoins
nutritionnels et ça
malheureusement c'est souvent un petit
peu plus cher mais vous voulez pas juste
se mettent les premiers en que vous
trouvez normalement fort ça marchera pas
donc les graines c'est sans pesticides
du coup s'en fout s'il est bio bio ne
veut pas dire sans pesticides ni mes
rares communes we bio ne veut pas dire
sans pesticides la bouillie bordelaise
est un pesticide autorisés en
agriculture bio et c'est absolument
horrible pour toute la petite phrase
jamais
donc bien on veut pas forcément dire
sans pesticides ont pour projet
attention ils avaient des alizés les
étiquettes
le pain à proscrire en france à
proscrire au maximum et bien le pain
c'est pas bon pour l'état c'est ça on
couvre alpes en fait c'est un peu comme
si vous mangez des cookies et tous les
records il adore ça donner du poids aux
canards ils sont à fond dessus le
problème c'est qu'après il faut pas
manger les alpes dont ils ont besoin et
qu'ils sont elles viennent d'initier ce
qui fait qu'ils vont avoir des tas de
défauts notamment pour les cats ont de
croissance et pour les adultes bas il
vous faut mourir prématurément de de
problèmes cardiaques m donc ne donnait
pas de banjo c'est pas ce dont ils ont
besoin de manière générale dans les
passes on parle en mêlant les trucs
transformer en règle générale un départ
c'est pas une bonne idée pour les
oiseaux ou des trucs transformer mais
tous les animaux en fait le pain le pain
c'est horrible pour tous les animaux des
bandes beaucoup de croûtons ozanne par
exemple
donner des carottes pommes ces cas-là
mais ouais enfin c'est pourquoi les
petits pois pour les canards sénégal
mais oui le pain à jamais c'est pas
surtout qu'en fait vous faites face à un
oiseau qui a divorcé vivement quel écart
voix qui venge des tisanes des petits
clips vraiment des micros de la
microfaune de temps en temps mais
vous pouvez pas l'utiliser du parti chez
comme nous de toute façon un régime de
pain blanc on est d'accord que ça fait
des dégâts c'est pareil pour lesquels
des mégots su c'est pas la peine de leur
donner
leurs mégots de cigarettes aux canards
c'est pas la peine non plus là
c'est très drôle de les voir manger à
mes goûts
oui on sent supérieur quand on regarde
le cannabis
beaucoup payent l'isf à un taux cinq
fois triste et l'aquarelle en arriver à
ce point là pourra manger matches que
j'ai vus faire donc je pense que c'est
important de look bien
d'accord donc pour se sentir supérieur
mais c'est triste on en arriver là trahi
moi j'ai quand même la question du coût
est ce qu'on peut faire quelque chose
pour les oiseaux vraiment car devant des
décors vides et les rapaces oui tu que
moi moi j'ai pas forcément envie de
nourrir tous ces oiseaux hyper ennuyeux
moi j'ai envie de nourrir des oiseaux
coude elle se cultive et proposer de la
viande en australie ça se fait pas mal
ils ont des
défis et des tablettes qui sont
absolument incroyable où il se vante
même du fromage de la viande et les
corvidés à oui ou non un vrai plateau
garni
ils regardent pas à la dépense par
contre les gars parce qu'il ya certes un
petit de viande pareil comme pour nous
mais surtout dangereuse pour les jeunes
enfants vient se renseigner alors
peut-être un petit topo sur une solution
intéresse mais il ya des trucs
typiquement les saucisses finalement
tout ce qui vient de transformer
des knacki des trucs comme ça c'est
certainement pas mais oui il est
possible de proposer des petites
languettes de viande
comme tout à fait c'est juste que du
coup de nettoyage de la majeure va soir
un peu différemment et tu mettras pas la
nourriture aussi longtemps sur la
mangeoire non ce n'est pas ce que ça va
tu élimines celle à pouvoir en fonction
de sa population et
des choses
oui il faut que les joueurs soient
évidemment placé suffisamment hauteur
pour éviter que les charnaysiennes
dessous du chien dehors parce que ça
fait des
boulettes mais c'est comme ça qu'ils
vont aussi pas hésité à se servir je
suis moi ça me dérange pas non plus dû
mourir des belettes mais
il ya des belettes poids de chez vous
s'il y en as c'est parce que vous n'en
avez une agglomération c'est quand même
assez rare
mais oui vous pouvez tout à fait nous
insistons cela sans aucun doute au
royaume uni une novice certains rapaces
comme ça il met des plateformes
voilà
mais du coup oui avoir une vengeance
dans la savane un gros impact sur la
faune sauvage il ya un autre truc aussi
très important mais d'assez c'est une
opération qui ont été faites en une bête
c'est les oiseaux qui avait souhaité sur
des maisons sont les autres qui avaient
accès à une mangeoire avaient un poids
voilà du corps qui étaient un peu plus
important que les russes n'avaient pas
accès à une mangeoire en hiver et du
coup si vous vient souvenirs sur des
petits oiseaux comme ça c'est que leur
foi à bari en fait au cours de la
journée c'est tellement petit que qui
vont perdre du poids très rapidement
simplement en essayant de sketchs ou
garder la température corporelle et au
fil de la journée s'ils ne se
nourrissent pas ils vont finir par
tomber en hypothermie et là c'est très
très dangereux pour le maso qui du coup
va finir apathique va pouvoir toucher
voir son humeur du tout parce
qu'évidemment il faut qu'on puisse aller
voler pour de la nourriture et si ce pas
le faire il va mourir - du potin
et donc avoir accès à une mangeoire se
permet à l'oiseau d'avoir une source de
nourriture fiable qui soit la présente
pour lui en hiver et qu'il puisse
utiliser régulièrement quand il en a
besoin sans avoir besoin de
de rester de partir chasser sans savoir
s'il va récupérer un truc ou pas et ça
ça permet d'augmenter la survie des
oiseaux traite de manière très important
que j'avais chief ici quelques ports
voilà donc ces petites maisons qui
avaient été supplémenté de la nourriture
elle avait à peu près 95% de chances de
survivre jusqu'au mois suivant en hiver
et au genre la totalité de l'hiver à peu
près il 70% de chances de passer l'hiver
tout simplement alors que les maisons
qui n'avaient pas été supplémenté donc
est pas axer mon choix elle par contre
elles avaient une probabilité de
sur dix sur la totalité de l'hiver qui
était à peu près de 37 tout simple donc
d'y passer de 70 % avec montjoire à 37%
mangeoire au niveau de la croix d'élite
et de sueur ça fait quand même une
différence qui est énorme sur un petit
oiseau comme ça donc vous voyez très
rapidement que vous pouvez beaucoup
aider les populations idéal pas recevoir
de supplémentation à condition de le
faire correctement évidemment ce n'était
pas n'importe quoi à manger ça
d'habitude
en hiver vous avez aussi ce qui
s'appelle des ce qu'ils appellent des
costards en anglais qui sont des
périodes de pointe
pendant cette période de froid intense
mais le soudan font pas disparaître
pendant les périodes de froid est tout
relatif on va dire tout à fait normal et
pendant ces épisodes de froid
en règle générale si vous nourrissez pas
il y avait une petite qui avaient été
faites suer qui prouvait que à peu près
un tiers de la population de maison
j'avais disparu suite à bas qui coûte
froid comme ça de plusieurs jours
s'était attiré suffisamment pour que les
mésanges en fait je n'ai plus accès à de
la nourriture parce qu'elle ne pouvait
plus voler il est trop froid lundi dans
une poterne et
al'inverse après avoir été supplémenté
lors d'un de ces petits épisodes de
froid il n'y avait eu que 7 % des
oiseaux supplémenté par l'abattoir qui
avait disparu dans cet épisode de froid
donc ça vous donne quand même une
différence entre soit un tiers des
maisons qui disparaissent en montjoire
soit seulement 7% qui nierait ça fait
une grosse différence
hacker pourrait se poser la question de
deux parce que c'est pas de la sélection
est ce qu'on est contre car pas la
sélection naturelle en nourrissant
une bonne question le problème c'est
qu'on en ait plus d'un mois ce serait
delà de nos jours c'est à dire que
l'état des populations étant ce qu'il
est c'est à dire en chute libre
si vous commencez à vous intéresser au
problème est ce qu'on devrait pas
supplémentaire qui sort parce que bronze
et un problème on va on va quand même
privilégié oiseaux qui sont pas
suffisamment forte au mieux oui mais en
ce moment personne survie de toute façon
il ya bien voilà reparti tout c'est déjà
les super winner de toute façon qu'il ya
déjà les super winner qui arrive donc tu
n'as pas ta pas trop de choix en fait on
supplément tant que tu vas simplement
revenir à un niveau mois
plus ou moins correct de survie chez les
ados tous un panier
on m'a juste combler ce petit gars
et ça c'est une bonne question
[Musique]
l'autre point important est un truc qui
revient souvent c'est que les mangeoires
favorise les maladies et oui c'est
quelque chose d'assez problématique
parce que sur une mangeoire vous allez
avoir plusieurs oiseaux de plusieurs
espèces différentes qui vont arriver
qu'ils vont se rencontrer sur la
mangrove qui normalement dans la tour ne
se rencontrent pas parce qu'ils voient
se fait sentir spécialement
généralement chacun de leur côté mais là
sur la mangeoire vous créer un lieu où
bat tout le monde va arriver et tout le
monde va manger ensemble se chamailler
parfois se taper dessus voire même se
blesser certaines fois ci vous fait pas
gaffe s'il n'y a pas assez à manger
toulon et puis vase c'est un lieu de
rencontre alors les deux rencontres le
problème c'est que c'est facile pour
transporter maladie
d'ailleurs que si on a un charisme avec
une maladie sous le monde veut la voir
surtout si vous n'avez pas nettoyé la
mangeoire pour moi c'est important de
nettoyer des morceaux et désinfecter
régulièrement même le plus malin des
corvidés n'est pas capable d'établir a
confié mans où un couvre-feu
et les besoins importants de masques
c'est vrai
c'est le dec ça
c'est d'avoir une taille standard pour
les hérons et les moineaux ce n'est pas
évident
[Rires]
non mais c'est vrai qu'on est enfin nous
on est évidemment coutumier de notre
président maintenant depuis nous
frappent depuis deux ans mais les
oiseaux ça fait combien de temps qu'ils
sont en état de l'épidémie kleppa bière
maintenant
plus de cinq ans dijon
jusqu'à quand ça se passe et pas à
l'homme et donc on n'en parlait pas mais
ça revient
la grippe aviaire à me faire aux oiseaux
ce que la grippe espagnole peu d'êtres
humains entre
les populations à faire
et surtout le lieu plusieurs épisodes
comme ça de problèmes qui ont été
dus aux mangeoires
et c'est pour ça que tu comptes faire
super gaffe quand on pose une main jean
jardin de vraiment bien la nettoyer un
grillage il faut voir que les oiseaux
ils sont très sensibles aux maladies je
pourrai enfin je m'étais renseigné un
peu de voir combien d'espèces c'est est
apte à cause d'une épidémie parce que
qu'ovide évidemment j'étais curieux de
savoir est ce qu'une espèce peut
réellement s'éteindre à cause d'une
maladie et le fait est que le peu
d'espèces dont on peut dire avec
certitude quel que soit son état à cause
d'une épidémie
passer des espèces d'oiseaux notamment
cet oiseau de l'archipel d'hawaï je me
rappelle plus le nom mais il ya un
oiseau qui se répand comme ça une
épidémie toute l'espèce
c'est possible toute chose les kids id
comme ça
y'a pas beaucoup de le problème c'est
quand on n'a pas beaucoup de membres de
l'espèce systra fils de fer séparant de
l'espèce parce qu'il ya beaucoup moins
de
ces individus qui sont capables de
développer des mécanismes de survie vous
avez beaucoup moins de variabilité non
pas
très rapide de décimer une espèce en
tire sur l'iss
malheureusement
bref il ya eu pas mal des pilotes comme
ça de
ce parasite ou de bâtir justement un
paradis qu'est connu des paléontologues
90 la semi colonial qui a fait encore
des ravages de mort sur les os des
mangeoires tu parce que ça se transmet
par contact et par l'eau contaminée ce
soir notamment et la trichomonas il ya
eu une histoire avec ça c'est qu'au
début ça a été développée on la trouvait
chez un pilon
c'était c'était en espagne et chez le
pigeon on pensait que c'était l'un des
seuls réseaux qu'ils étaient capables de
développer l'afrique comme nadal est à
l'époque du coup on avait installé des
plateformes de noël sage pour les
perdrix pour les faisans pour tout ce
genre de choses que les pigments
utilisés le sais parce que c'est plus ou
moins le même type de graines qu'ils
vont manger puisque même endroit il n'en
conçoit le chili a pas de souci donc ils
utilisaient les mêmes plateformes de
nourrissage et ce qui s'est passé c'est
que la trichomonase a finalement sauté
le pas entre le pigeon la perdrix le
faisant pendant que tous ces oiseaux là
et ça a été un gros problème
parce que ça a tué beaucoup beaucoup de
populations qui nous a tous alors on a
des moyens de se soigner comme nas
parasites donc on a pu en fait sept
enfants s'est rendu compte que c'étaient
les mangeoires qu'était problèmes qu'on
est chez à l'extérieur comme ça avait
coutume en devenait on a traité les
mangeurs ça c'est un truc qu'on peut
faire aussi des mangeoires c'est un
désavantage c'est qu'il faut traiter la
main charge directement et ont souffert
ou soigner tous les trois ans qui
viennent quittant pour les parasites
très efficace donc il avait fait ça à
l'époque que ça s'était très bien passé
le problème c'est que les pigeons et
tourterelles on continuer à transporter
ce parasite a été complètement soigner
complètement et il se retrouvait cette
fois ci au royaume uni chez des pigeons
et les taurens qui ont fini par douter
des mangeoires dans des jardins et il y
a eu certains passereaux d'esprit du cil
pinson qui ont été contaminés par cette
free comme naze et donc sa fille a sauté
encore une fois d'une espèce à l'autre
c'est grâce aux emplois et une fois que
j'ai été sur les personnes c'est chez
capable de se
retrouver dans à peu près tous les
petits oiseaux des jardins ont paraphé à
gauche et l'a pris comme menace de nos
jours fait encore beau travail à cause
de ça elle a été transmise grâce aux
immenses brest du pilon a plein d'autres
espèces et c'est vrai que c'est un réel
problème du coût des mangeoires si vous
désinfecter pas correctement sur cette
vague aph parce que vous mettez dans et
commet une erreur s'il passe il ya
beaucoup de maladies développées mais
c'est comme si on commence à manger dans
l'assiette sale ou vanille le seul à
avoir des problèmes ça c'est un problème
récurrent des mois voir c'est important
qu'ils
ont tendance à se dire c'est des animaux
on s'en fout winnipeg ils ont ils ont
fait pire comme ça je veux dire c'est
vrai
mais il faut nettoyer et désinfecter dit
c'est pas un environnement naturel de
nourrissage il faut faire des choses là
qu'ils ne font pas normalement comme de
compte un contact l'intéressent pas
voilà qui normalement nous perd pas dans
la nature et ça c'est un réel problème
il faut en être conscient et ce propos
la d'ailleurs dont clément joueurs
peuvent être un problème mais aussi une
solution parce que du coup grâce aux
mangeoires on a pu suivre en fait
l'évolution de certaines maladies à
travers les populations d'oiseaux et les
gens étaient capables de rapporter voilà
j'ai testé l'oiseau avec tels symptômes
à tel endroit gaouaoui effectivement du
coup la maladie reprendre a fait jusque
là on va pouvoir traiter jusque là donc
ça c'est aussi par contraint davantage
des mangeoires ça va permettre de suivre
l'évolution des nouvelles a dit dans la
population sauvage
grâce aux gens pourront explorer
[Musique]
voilà c'était quelques questions
aujourd'hui sur une chaise au sens qu'on
va s'arrêter là pour aujourd'hui la
vidéo c'est déjà cédé aux mineures nous
avons peut-être à suffisance il ya
d'autres questions non times les
habitués de la chaîne ne seront pas
shooter
c'est ça
voilà donc signer si vous avez d'autres
questions maintenant les commentaires et
j'essaierai d'y répondre et puis sinon
je vous souhaite une bonne année 2022
voilà
c'est le moment et puis à très bientôt
sur la chaîne
[Musique]